hagamos otro ejemplo de curvatura y en
este caso será un ejemplo en dos
dimensiones así que consideremos nuestra
función vectorial s que va a tener sólo
dos componentes va a ser x dt y 7 muy
bien y en específico esto va a ser
digamos va a ser t menos seno de t y uno
menos coseno de t muy bien y esta es la
curva que puse en el primer vídeo de
este tema de curvatura es la curva que
dijimos que imaginamos que estábamos en
una carretera y si nuestro volante se
atasca de repente se recorre un círculo
y en distintos puntos tendrá distintos
tamaños ese círculo y si la curvatura es
alta entonces estamos girando mucho así
el radio de curvatura sería pequeño así
que vamos a calcular la curvatura muy
bien de hecho en el vídeo anterior
nosotros desarrollamos un método en
donde dijimos bueno tenemos que calcular
la derivada del vector tangente unitario
verdad
respecto a la longitud de curva verdad
pero en este vídeo no lo vamos a hacer
así vamos a utilizar la fórmula que ya
tenemos verdad
donde nos dicen que la curvatura que
representamos con la letra griega cappa
se calcula como x prima donde prima
significa derivada verdad y aquí sería x
prima porque mi prima con mi prima
significa la segunda derivada menos de
prima por equis de prima y todo esto hay
que dividirlo entre x prima al cuadrado
más y prima al cuadrado y todo esto
elevado a la 3
muy bien y en realidad no me gusta eso
de memorizar las fórmulas y luego solo
esperar el momento a poder aplicarlas en
realidad a mí me agrada mucho tener
tener muy presente la idea de que
estamos calculando la derivada del
vector tangente unitario con respecto a
la longitud de curva muy bien esa es la
idea que hay detrás de toda esta fórmula
está muy bien así que vamos a calcular
entonces estas derivadas que necesitamos
para encontrar la curvatura entonces
necesitamos saber quién es x prima de
'the x prima dt sería derivar t menos
seno de t la derivada de t es uno y la
derivada de seno de tesco seno dt
entonces tendremos uno menos el coseno
de t veamos ahora quién es la derivada
de y la derivada de que tendremos
derivada de uno que es cero menos la
derivada del coseno dt que es menos seno
de t así que con este otro - se hace más
y tendremos solo
seno de t muy bien ahora fijémonos en
las segundas derivadas la segunda
derivada de x sería derivar 1 que nos da
0 - la derivada del coseno de hecho esta
expresión verdad es exactamente la misma
que tenemos acá así que podemos decir
que la derivada es seno de t verdad
ahora bien la segunda derivada de jette
pues sería derivar seno de t y eso sería
coseno de t muy bien entonces podríamos
ya calcular fácilmente nuestra curvatura
verdad la curvatura simplemente hay que
sustituir todo esto x prima de 31 - el
coseno de t y luego mi prima que es
coseno de t menos de prima que es el
seno de t y xvii prima que es el seno de
t entonces esto podríamos ponerlo al
cuadrado verdad y luego tendremos que
dividir entre x prima al cuadrado que es
uno menos el coseno de t al cuadrado más
y prima al cuadrado que es seno cuadrado
de t y todo esto irá elevado a la tres
medios muy bien y ahí está aquí está la
respuesta simplemente aplicar la fórmula
y obtienes la respuesta verdad así por
ejemplo cuando dibujaba la curva y pedía
a la computadora que dibujara el círculo
apropiado pues en esencia no hicimos
todo el proceso de derivar respecto a la
longitud de arco verdad en lugar de eso
sólo nos vimos a la fórmula y con eso se
puede al final hallar el radio de
curvatura